desperate times clearly call for
desperate measures so much so a
conservative government is talking to
supermarkets about how to bring down
prices a very unturry intervention any
scheme would be voluntary and apply to
Essentials like milk and breadth to ease
the cost of living but already the
industry says it won't work
there is no money left in the supply
chain to cut costs so you know the
government should just leave it to the
market which has done a great job
Farmers processes and retailers in
trying to keep costs down as much as
possible but the pledge itself is
completely meaningless but the idea may
well have meaning for Shoppers given the
rising prices food prices have risen by
19 in the last year some items even more
milk for example up 30 percent but
there's a fear that capping prices in
the big supermarkets could hit smaller
retailers at places like this who could
lose business as customers increasingly
look to cut costs numbers of customers
are down on what they were a few months
ago sales at Martin gooding's cheese
counter had already dropped off after he
was recently forced to put up prices
exposed to his own Rising costs his
little room to maneuver we've got to
make a profit that's what we're here for
you know we're not here just to supply
cheese we're here to make money out of
doing it at the end of the day so you
know he gets to the point where you know
you can only you can only cut prices for
so much and then then you're sort of
you're losing money and you run the risk
of going out of business
concerns that are no doubt shared by
Dairy Farmers who have long complained
of squeezed margins the price of milk is
a historic sore spot voluntary price
caps do exist in France where prices
tend to be higher for supermarkets here
though analysts say it would be much
harder they're fighting against
and bread milk and butter have come down
but retailers have to retain their
margins and further down the chain Dairy
Farmers have got to be able to make some
money at the end of the day so I'm I'm
very puzzled the plan is said to be at
the drawing board stage at this rate it
might not get much further Ivor Bennett
Sky News